so with the secret Invasion show coming
out this week I thought it'd be really
cool to make a video that basically runs
over like the origin and the history of
the Scrolls but specifically why they
chose to invade Earth during secret
Invasion at least in the comics anyway
and I just thought this would be kind of
cool to do it a little bit different
right so uh when it comes to the Scrolls
in Marvel Comics we don't really know
exactly where they came from We're
largely just kind of left to assume that
by whatever Manner and whatever means
their race evolved on their Homeworld of
scrollos to the point that we were
initially introduced to them now the way
this worked is that in the very early
days of the Scrolls and I'm talking like
billions of years ago the celestials
showed up to scrollos now this was part
and parcel to the celestial role of just
traveling across the cosmos and just
experimenting on different races a lot
of you are familiar with the creation of
the deviants and the eternals on Earth
Earth was one of the last worlds where
that was done long before the celestials
ever showed up and visited Humanity they
went to like the cree and the Dune and
the smart toy and all these different
races the Scrolls were one of the
earliest races to be experimented on but
the way this worked is that much like
what you're aware of when it comes to
humanity that the celestials had
actually modified the genes of the
entirety of the scroll race the
difference is that the whole race was
split into thirds that the first group
which were the deviants had their genes
destabilized which gave them the ability
to shapeshift but it also introduced a
caveat which we'll talk about here in a
second the second group had their genes
modified so they could basically tap
into like Cosmic Power and they became
the eternals then the third group much
like with Humanity had their genes
modified so that at some future point in
time they would start developing Powers
now unlike the human race where the
deviants were defeated through a
combination of the eternals and the
celestials on the planet of scrollos the
deviance wiped out the prime Scrolls
like that they just destroyed them on
the spot and then following that they
went to war against the eternals now
within Marvel Comics there's a couple
different accounts as to why this
happened the original origin basically
says that the deviants who were led by
sligert ended up just deciding that they
were their rightful heirs to the world
and then wiped out the prime Scrolls and
went to war against the eternals in 1993
with Avengers issue number 371 it was
actually established that there was a
villain named Tantalus who was created
by the dreaming Celestial and goaded the
Deviant Scrolls into going to war with
everybody else honestly the whole story
from Avengers 371 it's been ignored and
that guy hasn't shown up since the 1990s
so you can largely just ignore it and go
with the original origin But whichever
one you choose to go with the overall
gist here is that queen sligert and the
deviants once they went to war with the
eternals basically wiped out pretty much
all of them and in fact there was only
one Survivor this guy's name was clippin
now the way this worked is that clippin
as an eternal scroll understood the role
that the entirety of both races played
and he realized the caveat that the
deviants had to contend with and so in
order to save his life he actually
Bartered with slugert and then revealed
the truth of the deviance modification
and what he told them is that while the
modification of their genes by the
celestials did give them the ability to
shapeshift it introduced a half-life and
future unchecked mutations what this
meant is that while shape-shifting was
the ability they had now as each new
generation emerged this mutation would
turn into something more drastic and it
would become more and more Extreme as
time went on beyond that each new
generation would live a shorter life
than the generation before it so
effectively if the deviants wiped out
every other kind of scroll across the
entirety of the Andromeda galaxy and the
scrollos planet then it was only a
matter of time before the Scrolls simply
ceased to exist because there would be
some generation that would emerge that
would be incapable of having Offspring
and it would just lead to their
Extinction and so in order to ensure
that the scroll race could continue to
thrive clippin and slugert sort of
either merged or had how to kind of
marrying ceremony but by whatever Manner
and whatever means basically brought a
kind of combined modification to the
genes of the Scrolls which introduced a
sort of
Eternal Gene allowing them to live
longer effectively nullifying the
half-life effect that the celestials had
installed but at the same time allowing
the Scrolls to go forward as the
quote-unquote de facto leaders of their
home world and even the Andromeda galaxy
itself now this unification of sluggert
and Clemen gave us what we call the
pantheon or the book of Worlds it's the
central religious text of the Scrolls so
think of it as their race is equivalent
of like the Bible for Humanity or
whatever religious scripture you ascribe
to and so following this one of the
things that the deviants were completely
unaware of is the fact that a portion of
their sect had actually branched off and
started meddling with like dark magic
and while this dark magic did just like
modify their appearance and turn them
into these almost grotesque creatures it
Amplified their power on a whole new
level this group started calling itself
the dire race and so following the war
between the deviants and the eternals
the dire race made their move and went
to war against the deviance now where
the deviants lacked power against the
dire wraiths they made up for this with
just sheer numbers so literally the dire
race were outnumbered by a ratio of like
a thousand to one and so ultimately
because the deviants were still
incredibly powerful albeit not as
powerful as the dire rates this
ultimately meant to the dire race simply
couldn't win against such a huge number
of deviant Scrolls so they ultimately
retreated from scrollos they traveled to
a place called the dark nebula and then
set up residents on a world that they
started calling wraith world and so in
effect with no one to really challenge
their dominance over scrollos and even
the Andromeda galaxy the Deviant Scrolls
started developing Interstellar travel
and then effectively conquered the
entirety of the Andromeda galaxy any
race that existed on any other world
throughout this area was totally
eradicated and the planet was colonized
and so for a time once this was done
there really wasn't any need for Warfare
anymore there was no real need for the
Deviant Scrolls to engage in conflict
because they were totally self-contained
but there were other Empires that
existed in the universe during this time
specifically on the far side of the
universe you had a group called The Shia
now the Shia race had actually risen to
prominence not by wiping out any
opposition forces but by actually
conscripting them into their own Empire
much the same way that the Roman Empire
did here on Earth the difference is that
unlike the Roman Empire where once you
were conquered you spoke the Roman
language and you followed the Roman
Theology and so on and so forth the Shia
Empire still allowed a measure of
autonomy among those different races
that they'd conquered but this was
beneficial for the shiar because they
could literally take the technology the
intelligence the various capabilities of
these conscripted races and incorporated
into their own Empire and effectively
live up to the idea that like this
Empire itself was greater than the sum
of its parts and so what the Scrolls did
is in witnessing that started doing the
same thing so one of the first worlds
they went to was a place called holla
which at that point in time was occupied
by two different races the cree and the
kotati and so what ended up happening is
the Scrolls grabbed a portion of the
cree and the kotadi and then took them
to the blue area of Earth's moon but
when the Scrolls brought the cree and
the kotadi to this place they dropped
them off and then gave them a Year's
worth of supplies simply stating to
build whatever it is that they felt like
building whatever spoke to them the most
and that in one year the Scrolls would
return once that one year was over the
Scrolls came back they visited both
groups and actually found that the cree
had built like this giant technological
Citadel whereas the kotadi had built a
jungle and because they saw that the
kotadi's more peaceful way was more in
line with the scroll belief system since
they had long since abandoned their
warring ways that ultimately the Scrolls
chose the kotadi to be brought into the
scroll Empire this pissed off the Creed
at no end and so in response to this
judgment the cree had killed Emperor
dorak who was the one that oversaw this
whole project they killed him and his
entire delegation wiped out the kotadi
who were on the moon and then took the
ship of the Scrolls and flew back to
Cree space following that they used
their technicians to basically reverse
engineer scroll Interstellar travel and
then waged war against the Scrolls this
kicked off what we call the cree scroll
War this is a conflict that went on for
millions of years I mean millions and
millions of years now we don't really
know the ins and outs of the cree scroll
War we know like seminal moments in the
conflict and we know that there was a
point when it came close to Earth and
almost wiped out the entirety of Earth
but the reality is that that was
basically at the tail end of the cree
scroll war and in fact it was actually
following a lull where the war had
basically cooled off kind of dropped off
and then in turn picked back up again
now the reason why this war had dropped
off was because in an effort to
basically defeat the score rolls and
then seize control of the universe that
the Supreme intelligence who's kind of
like this religious and political leader
of the cree had sent a single soldier to
a place called The Citadel of light and
Shadow and the reason why was because
within this Citadel is What's called the
crystal of ultimate Vision now when a
person enters into the Citadel and then
approaches the crystal what it will do
is it'll immediately just start showing
them these just incredible displays of
the things that they can do right just
the massive amount of power they can
have this is actually a test that what
the crystal does is that when an
individual tries to seize control of it
and does it from a place of selfishness
it'll immediately freeze The
evolutionary progression of their race
so they'll basically become stagnant
quite literally the universe will pass
them by on the other hand if a person
seizes the crystal for selfless reasons
meaning they want to like cure hunger
throughout the universe or something
like that then the crystal will allow
them to use it such as it was this Cree
Soldier sent there on a mission that was
largely selfish it was done on behalf of
the cree to kill the Scrolls and to
conquer the universe and so this led to
the freezing of The cree's evolutionary
process now realizing that fixing this
superseded all other causes the Supreme
intelligence recalled the cree warships
from scrollos and then started working
on the universal inhuman project and
then built the accuser core but with the
War I guess cooling down if you want to
call it that that the Scrolls started
returning back to their state of
basically being a more peaceful and
exploratory race and so during this time
what ended up happening is the Scrolls
were led by an emperor whose name we
don't really know in fact he's never
actually given a name in Marvel Comics
The reason why this guy was important
though is because what he did is he
instructed His science Guild to start
focusing on tapping into extra
dimensional energies what they ended up
doing was actually ripping a hole into
another place that was called the Beyond
verse right that's home of the beyonders
the Scrolls didn't really understand
what they were doing and the only thing
they knew about what they'd done is that
energy from that location had been
siphoned off and put into a stasis Cube
this is where the Cosmic Cube comes from
in Marvel Comics and so what ended up
happening is the Emperor became obsessed
with this Cosmic Cube he literally
started talking to it he was praising it
above everything else even his own
Empire it was an obsession but the
Cosmic Cube itself actually started
developing sentience and mirroring the
very mannerisms and even personality of
the Mad scroll Emperor and so going
insane The Cosmic Cube wiped out
two-thirds of the Andromeda galaxy and
then just took off but with their entire
Empire basically disappearing in the
blink of an eye this led to the Scrolls
kind of reverting to a barbarous state
and the Empire effectively splitting
into factions being led by like Petty
strong men and Warlords and so again
this continued on for some measure of
time until we end up getting to a guy
called Emperor dorak VII now this guy is
incredibly important in relation to
secret Invasion for a couple different
reasons the first is because this guy
was approached by a woman named princess
varanki now princess varanki was part
and parcel to a religious sect that was
more zealots than anything else but
closely followed the pantheon and the
Book of Worlds and what this prophesies
was two things the first is that there
would be a Annihilation white a wave of
Destruction that would spread across the
universe and the second thing it
prophesies was the destruction of the
scroll Homeworld Now by this point in
time the scroll home world had actually
been moved from scrollos to a place
called tarnax IV and so Emperor dorak
had largely dismissed for ranki right
just kind of saw her as a religious
zealot and then she was just cast off
and thrown into a Barren world and just
left there presumably to die to the
elements or whatever the case happened
to be but funny enough the prophecy
actually turned out to be true the first
part of this prophecy was an event that
we refer to as Annihilation that
annihilist from the Negative Zone had
invaded the main Marvel Universe and all
almost wiped out everything in existence
of course ultimately annihilus was
stopped and the event came to a close
the second part of the prophecy which
came in the form of the destruction of
the scroll Homeworld was due to Galactus
now up to this point in time something
to know is that Galactus had been around
since the very beginning of the universe
in fact he was born into the universe's
creation and the first world he
destroyed set him on a course of just
traveling from life-sustaining world to
life-sustaining World consuming it and
then effectively destroying all life
that existed there now when Galactus
Came Calling only one of two things
would happen either you were a race that
was technologically advanced enough to
cloak your world so Galactus would pass
by not knowing you were there or you
were not one of those races and your
world would be destroyed that was just
that was just the way that it was right
Galactus is just that powerful the
Scrolls were a race that historically
always been able to cloak their world
now what ended up happening here is that
by this point in time Galactus had a
different Herald it was actually a girl
named Frankie Ray who went by the code
name Nova but she was able to see the
scrolled Homeworld and so Galactus
approached the Scrolls powerless to do
anything basically watched as their
world was completely obliterated and
most of them tried to flee not only a
few of them managed to get away but
those who did survive had actually
realized that the prophecy of a ranki
and the Book of Worlds was accurate so
they basically descended into religious
zealotry they went and they grabbed
varanki and they brought her back and
she became the new Empress of the scroll
race now backtrack here for a second
during the reign of Emperor Doric VII
and when the crease world war was
basically starting to pick back up that
the crease World War coming as close to
Earth as it did almost led to the
Earth's destruction and so in the
aftermath of that the leaders of the
Earth's superhero communities formed the
Illuminati one of the first things they
did is they traveled to the scroll
Homeworld and they effectively said if
your conflict comes close to Earth again
we will will eradicate you in response
the Scrolls basically knocked out the
Illuminati then they tortured them and
copied their genes and stored them and
so following the destruction of tarnax 4
at the hands of Galactus and Princess
varanki being brought in as the leader
of the scroll race what she did is she
offered a new prophecy that said that
according to Cleveland and those guys
that the Scrolls were destined to seize
control of Earth that that place would
become their new home now whether or not
this was actually in the book of Worlds
isn't fully known the book of Worlds did
make reference to like a new home for
the Scrolls following the destruction of
their world but Earth just kind of seems
to be the place that was chosen by
Marvel because they wanted to write
secret Invasion but what princess
varanki learned here is that while
Emperor Doric was dead and most of the
squirrel race was destroyed that while
they did have the genes of the
Illuminati that what the Scrolls had
secretly been doing is that in their
different skirmishes with Earth
superheroes they were sampling their DNA
and so the science Guild of the Scrolls
was trying to find a way to allow them
to replace superheroes while going
undetected the way they did this was
genius under any normal circumstance a
deviant scroll can just shapeshift and
turn into any superhero or any super
villain or anybody they want to but for
someone like a telepath or somebody like
Wolverine who can smell the scent of a
particular person they would pick up on
it like that and in fact it happened
multiple times in Marvel Comics in order
to get around that what the swirls did
is they would actually take the memories
of any particular superhero presumably
stored inside their own DNA and they
would plant those memories into the mind
of the scroll literally this scroll
would undergo mental conditioning to the
point that they genuinely believed they
were that person so that when a scroll
duplicate of a superhero showed up on
Earth to a telepath there was no
difference but hanked him in fact
yellowjacket as he was known at that
point in time in Marvel he was a scroll
replicant but nobody knew because as far
as their that scroll was concerned he
was actually Hank pimp so if a telepath
scanned his mind they'd see all the
memories of Hank Pym and what's going on
inside his head is everything that Hank
Pym would think he was a genius maneuver
but the other part of this is that
varenki realized that a head-on conflict
against pretty much any of the superhero
teams would lead to the destruction of
what was in effect the fragile scroll
Empire so what she did is she started
planning the secret Invasion under the
guise of Spider-Woman she showed up on
Earth and then she started manipulating
things behind the scenes so like this
superhero Civil War kind of the events
of House of M or at least the events
that led into it to a degree but not
directly things like that those were all
basically the manipulations of varenki
and any and other scroll replicants that
have been placed on Earth that stretched
everywhere from your basic superhero
Team all the way up to like governmental
agencies it was crazy how far they got
right it was kind of amazing how many
Scrolls had actually infiltrated earth
now what's funny about this is that this
entire project would have gone off
without a hitch and the Scrolls would
have been secretly able to overtake the
entirety of humanity and then by the
time anybody realized what was going on
the number of Scrolls would have
drastically exceeded the number of
surviving humans and they would have
just been wiped out and that would have
basically been it but Nick Fury was
actually the guy who saved the day at
least it was Nick Fury and then the
Avengers at the same time so Nick Fury
was a guy who was like suspicious of
everything right like everyone and
everything and what he ended up
realizing is that there was something
off about Contessa Valentina and so when
the two of them had basically slept
together in a room she left and then
Nick Fury used a kind of projector that
basically made him appear invisible and
followed her and then he saw her
speaking with somebody else and then
realized at least by scanning her that
she was actually a scroll replicant and
so that's when he realized Scrolls were
secretly replacing superheroes on earth
now at the same time this was going on
you had a character named Elektra who
turned out to be a scroll and that was
discovered by a combination of the
Illuminati the Fantastic Four and the
Avengers and so this kicked off The
Secret Invasion event when all the
superheroes on earth started realizing
that Scrolls were replacing them and
they didn't know if the person they were
talking to was a scroll replicant or the
original person this was even more
complicated by the fact that a scroll
ship ended up crash landing in a Savage
land and all these different superheroes
started emerging they all pretty much
turned out to be Scrolls but even the
people themselves who were on Earth and
always believed that they were these
different superheroes didn't know their
own identities Iron Man actually had
this massive crisis where he didn't know
if he was a scroll or if he was actually
Tony Stark who had lived his whole life
that's why secret invasion was such an
amazing event because you had people who
didn't even really know who they were
having said that um make sure you guys
check the comment down below we're gonna
wrap this video up but make sure you
guys check the comment down below you'll
see a link to the full story for secret
Invasion where we run over the entire
thing it's a really really really cool
event but uh yeah we're gonna bring this
to an end let me know what you guys
think about this whole format you know
let me know down in the comments section
and I will catch you all later
peace